I was on Erasmus in 1997 I did my
thesis research for my
thesis in aix en provence which was a
thesis on political Islam
my passion was to study this topic
and without Erasmus I could not have done it
[Music]
I remember a lot  well that was meanwhile
the impact with a beautiful city
very lively very young and above all
I remember that it was for me the first real
experience of autonomy
[Music]
my name is pierpaolo I am Italian and I am
21 years old my study essences politics
la freie  universitaet di berlin but i'm
doing the erasmus in france
the primary reason was to
improve the language and so i was
interested in learning french for
my future career
definitely the data with the language because it was
the first time i
actually used  french is my
french today although not perfect it
derives from those months it allowed me to
have an experience of contact with
other cultures and it is more or less what
i would like to do in life therefore the
possibility of forging relationships with
people from other countries  and at the same
time to be perhaps even more
conscious of my culture than
that of others to also develop
a European consciousness
[Music]